[Music]
so the whole marketing Ploy behind this
is like the new Dynamic Island which is
like it's like the main thing in the
commercials is that thing oh yeah
Dynamic Island who gives a [ __ ] who get
yeah exactly yeah who cares uh Christian
congratulations Christian Diamond
pistols that's his music oh I know isn't
that crazy no I wonder how that even
happened so they have a music supervisor
who's actually extremely tapped into
music okay just knows everyone and
anyone it's crazy so if you're an indie
band The Dream my understanding is it's
a meme amongst Indie artists is that you
make your hit that goes in an apple
commercial and then that's what makes
your band successful I see it's crazy if
he knows about Diamond pistols
[Music]
you would not veto us being in a [ __ ]
Apple commercial I wouldn't veto it but
come on it would be that would be great
that would be sick dude if they're like
can you come do the Walkman yeah thing
for Apple
it'd be begrudging they're like can you
it'd be really great we got this new
iPhone coming out we think it'd be a
great campaign for you to remember the
tick tock dance that people did out of
your song can you do that for us
I would say Tim I would love nothing
more and Tim's gonna do it with you
[Applause]
right in the middle Tim Cook I would do
that [ __ ] with tears
I'll be weeping on camera yeah but what
if they like what if it was like Prime
Time commercial money I would be crying
on camera doing it into into bills yeah
yeah we'd be doing it right there next
to all the live golf guys
yeah the dynamic Island yeah who gives a
[ __ ]
it's not cool I don't think it's like
the stupid it's like they've reached the
end there's no more Innovations in
phones anymore no so like this is the
coolest thing is this little piece of
the screen that moves I would say that
no phone company should ever make a
commercial again until we can game off
these things like I can plug my monitor
and a mechanical keyboard into this I
can just game in a cafe you probably can
already to some degree yeah but I want
that good yeah a good good yeah yeah
that'll happen do you remember like
we're at the point now where it's just
like yeah there's nothing fun like you
don't get that feeling like you do right
now with AI with AI it's like every
[ __ ] week yeah something new is
happening that that is Leaps and Bounds
better than the previous thing yeah like
this like the video thing that we kind
of glossed over uh the fact that you
just create videos with AI where you're
like hey landscape of this and just make
a video for you remove that Tower and
remove it that's [ __ ] insane yeah
well it's kind of crazy too when you
compare that to the conversation we had
about like GPT three like six months ago
yeah six to eight months ago totally
when we're just sort of I was putting
out the idea like oh man what if you
know imagine like directors using
something like this and just
storyboarding and an entire like
commercial or something being like okay
yeah you know subject foreground this is
that and like what about this as an idea
like a premier plug-in that basically
parsed all the text or all the spoken
word and like a podcast episode or video
or whatever just like what is that
editing app that you can use where like
automatically remove the spaces it's for
podcasts specifically descript that like
basically parses all the spoken word
It'll like list it out to you and then
you can just like choose to remove
certain things just based off the words
and then I'll edit that part out of the
video interesting so what if we did
something like made a plug-in that was
kind of the same thing but it just
automatically added AI generated b-roll
on top for exactly what we were talking
about
that'd be sick right that'd be great
yeah someone will make it in the next
three months so someone's probably
already working on that and it'll
probably be out tomorrow that's what's
so crazy about this whole world it's
going to be interesting too how Adobe
for example tries to tie in all of these
like stock footage services and stuff
yeah imagine you have this like major
like stock footage library and you're
like oh yeah we'll just build this AI
plug-in to take advantage of all this
you know like that or adobe Forks
whatever mid-journey type thing and then
it creates something that well I'm
giving Adobe a lot of credit like
they're going to write new software yeah
but like they take their entire stock
photo library and create like a more
robust AI that works off that and can
create custom stock footage yes exactly
[ __ ] like that's probably already
happening I mean the GitHub AI thing is
[ __ ] crazy it's basically like a
co-pilot so in your oh yes text yes
editor or whatever yeah it'll just like
it it so basically they took all the
code on GitHub everything that's ever
been put and hosted on GitHub yeah they
ran it through this AI trained it so
that it knows the best code in the world
right and now when you're writing code
it'll just automatically complete
whatever you want to happen
and right away they launched this and
instantly it was a billion dollars a
year that they were making off this yeah
I'm just laughing this just completely
wipes out all those um scammy code
School Services learn how to code in
eight weeks yeah it's also kind of a
funny [ __ ] you to like all these genius
software programmers that like put their
[ __ ] up for free yeah like wrote this
beautiful library or beautiful API yeah
posted on GitHub and github's like oh
it's sick thank you thank you
I mean you kind of have to you still
have to understand what you're writing
yeah like you can't be a total [ __ ] but
I mean this would have been so it would
have been sick massively helpful yeah
um Noel would you mind writing like five
or six apis today we need this tomorrow
yeah no problem yeah
[Music]
leaving at five yep well now that whole
idea of needing to validate yourself in
media that's going to be a reality very
quickly what do you mean there's going
to be a point where in media and as
people we're gonna have to like create a
system where we're validating like yes
that is me in this media oh yeah you
know just because like deep faking yeah
you take like a robust AI thing to
create video and then some deep faking
software that just gets more and more
evolved which is like what it's like a
couple years out probably and then yep
that shit's Gonna Be Wild the first
couple instances of that like the first
few people to get blackmailed by that
it's gonna be rough yeah
it's not going to be important people
it'll just be like scammers on the
internet like preying on the remaining
Facebook people yeah hey Dave from
Indianapolis we caught you at the club
flirting with this girl I mean I'm too
old I don't I would never there's no
Club in my town there's not a single one
just send it
that looks like me holy [ __ ] out I don't
even I never met that girl never kissed
that girl this does look fun though
yeah that does look fun this is in Las
Vegas Nevada
holy hell Dave you're getting away from
the point venmo is two grand right now
wow this looks like a blast Dave Focus
I've never been to Las Vegas before I
would love to go oh is this what it
would be like so this is me there wow
that's a cool video how'd you make that
we're sending this to your wife right
now go ahead show her bro the scams will
get crazy it'll be like some scammers in
India finding a family on Facebook
taking images of their son and then
putting it in video and then sending the
mom video Yeah from like a mock Facebook
profile like hey Mom
can you send me a quick 200 bucks I'm
down here at the whatever damn that's
scary yeah
I want to think about the positive
things
yeah well like the Earth will be too hot
to scam at that point yeah okay good